لترسيم الحدود البحري بين لبنان
والكيان الاسرائيلي وحكومة
ايطاليا وبولندا والكثير من دول
اوروبا. القارة العجوز الى اين?
الباكستانية تصدر مذكرة باعتقال
رئيس الوزراء المقالي من منصبه
الكيان متفائلة بشأن الوساطة
الامريكية. في بريطانيا تظاهر
لاسلحة المهاجمين. ومن تهديد
الولايات المتحدة الى تهديد حلف
قادرة بعون الله على حرمان
السعودي والاماراتي من موارده
امهل المتحدث الشركات النفطية
العاملة في الامارات والسعودية
يعلنون تحديهم لامريكا فلماذا لا
نفعلها نحن؟ وهنا تركيا تشير
بالوعود ولكن مالا انسيت انك
وقعت وتم الانضمام ليضيف ارض
العاب النار هنا افادت وزارة
الدفاع اليابانية بان كوريا
لجنون هذا الرجل. انه لا يتوقف
حقا عن اطلاق الصواريخ وكأنها
والهدف الا تغفو اعينها عن
مراقبة الصين والضغط عليها. فهل
هذه الشراكات هي اخر الحلول
للامريكان? صواريخ ضال. الهواية
الصاروخية اصبحت روتينا يوميا
لدى زعيم كوريا الشمالية. يا
التنين الصيني شموعه في جزيرة
تايوان. ليأتي التصفيق من روسيا.
الحديثة. نعم هكذا هنأ بوتين
الصين وذلك نقلا عن وكالة
عسكرية اوكرانية ولهذا السبب قد
تكون الاسابيع القليلة المقبلة
عالمي اكثر ديمقراطية وعدالة
لمواجهة التهديدات والتحديات
وقتا خطيرا بشكل خاص كما يتفق
مجموعة من المسؤولين الامريكيين
ستسقط القنابل النووية في حال تم
اطلاقها. يرى بعض المحللين
مزيدا من العقوبات على روسيا.
ويا لهذه العقوبات التي لا
الروسية تعلن انسحابها من بلدة
ليمانا الاستراتيجية بعد ان حصرت
من قبل اوكرانيا. ولكني اشتم
رائحة حيلة روسية سيجمع بوتين
رمضان قديروف زعيم جمهورية
الشيشان في بيان غاضب ينتقد فيه
متوعدة ومهددة ان بوتين بقراره
سيتلقى عقوبات موجعة وفارضة
لقاء الوزيرة الالمانية بنظيرها
الاوكراني انطلقت صفارات الانذار
تنتهي. المانيا هي الاخرى غضبت
من الفشل الامريكي في مجلس
الامل ولم يستطع بايدن بوعده
لاوكرانيا. هناك لم تستطع امريكا
حسن. والمصاريك باي بنك. مباراة
حماسية واهداف خرافية. والنتيجة
كارثية مئة وسبعون. ليس هدفا بل
قتيلا. نعم هي مجزرة كروية في
فليأت الى ساحة الحرب. نعم فقد
اعلن انتصاره متحديا الغرب ولم
معاداة امريكا. بينما يرى
المراقبون ان هذه الحملة لا تمثل
كلمتها. لقد خرج الدب من كهفه
جائعا. ومن اجل ان يسكت ضجيج
اجل التقرب للالية. شاب هندي
يدفن نفسه حيا. الشرطة
صفقة ايرانية امريكية محتملة
معتقلين مقابل الافراج عن اموال
مجمدة لطهران. مقتحمة بنك لبنان
والمهجر ترد على عرض الفنان تيم
المتحدة تبدأ في تمرير قرار
امريكي على طاولة مجلس الامن
الادارة الامريكية لكن تظل
الجزائر هي الدولة العربية
يكن كلامه هباء منثورا ليخرج هنا
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قائلا.
النووي. وخطوة جديدة يتشارك بها
التنين الصيني والدب الروسي تربك
وهكذا كان رد موسكو. يا الهي يا
له من رد سريع ومخيف. وفتى بوتين
الجزائر باعتبارها داعما لروسيا
في حرب اوكرانيا وتطبيق قانون
ملتزمة بالهدنة. مشيرا الى ان كل
شيء محتمل ووارد لان لدى شعبه
بقوله قد اعذر من انذر. الاحداث
والتطورات. بقيادة عضوة الكونجرس
فرصة اخيرة لترتيب اوضاعها وسرعة
تلك الدول ما دامت دولهم غير
اندونيسيا وذلك اثر مشاجرة بين
المشجعين في ارضية الملعب. ومن
اذا اصر على حرمان شعبنا اليمني
من موارده. والبادئ اظلم. وقد
غيرنا? هكذا يسأل الامريكان
انفسهم. ها نحن نعود مجددا. بعد
الجمهوري سبعة وعشرون عضوا من
الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
الحرب للاشتعال بين اليمن ودول
خليج هنا المتحدث باسم الجيش
اليونانية. وماذا بعد يا
اردوغان? اليس لديك احد لتهدده
ويؤكد رفضه لقرار واشنطن حول رفع
حظر بيع الاسلحة لقبرص
بعرقلة انضمام السويد وفنلندا
الى الناتو حتى يتم الوفاء
وزير الخارجية الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن للمطالبة بفرض عقوبات على
الاقوى بمواقفها. لذا يحسب لها
الامريكان الف حساب. اتفاق
التابع لجماعة الحوثيين في اليمن
العميد يحيى سريع قواتنا المسلحة
القدرة على اخذ حقه متى ما سدت
امامه الطرق السلمية وحذرهم
روسيا والصين. لكن ماذا ان
سبقتها بكين الى ذلك? ومن
والاوروبيين. فلا تذهب بعيدا.
يبدو ان بوتين سيجعل الايام
الاسف فقد فشل هذا المشروع لتعود
امريكا حاملة وراءها اذيال خيبة
سليمان. وذلك بهدف تعزيز شراكتها
البحرية ولتجد مكانا فيه سفنها.
الطائرات الى حرب التحالفات.
نعم. فهنا امريكا تعزز شراكتها
الولايات المتحدة من الشرطة
التركية الارقام التسلسلية
هنا قائد القوات الامريكية يتحدث
الجيش الصيني يمكن ان يكون اول
سليمان صويلو ليأتي الرد سريعا
على هذه المزاعم. حيث طلبت
الناتو باكمله. الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان يهدد مجددا
هدنة دامت لستة اشهر وبعد تجديد
الهدنة مرتين متتاليتين. هل تعود
في اسبوع واحد. بينما هنا
اليابان تدين الاطلاق وتعتبره
باصابع الاتهام الى واشنطن وتقول
انها ضالعة في هجوم استهدف اقليم
مرسين جنوبي البلاد وذلك بتصريح
رسمي من وزير الداخلية التركي
مع جزر المحيط الهادئ لمواجهة
الصين حيث قامت واشنطن بالتوقيع
على تأسيس جمهورية الصين الشعبية
علينا توحيد قوانا لبناء نظام
هكذا يقولها الخبراء العسكريون.
بينما امريكا التي تزعم انها
عالم اساسا فموسكو تحضر
المفاجآت. هدية بوتين للصين.
الكريملين. وماذا عن الهدية هنا?
وبمناسبة مرور ثلاثة وسبعين عاما
تصعيد استفزازيا. تركيا تقولها
في وجه امريكا. اذا اصبح الجميع
زعيمة العالم بداية من الجو. من
يسيطر على الجو فقد التهم الارض
قوة في العالم تصنع طائرات الجيل
السادس. بكين فعلتها فستصبح
على الاقل اطلق من بيونج يانج
وماذا ان كانت الاربعة هي صواريخ
تقارير روسية تقول لا تستعدوا
لكأس العالم. فلن يكون هناك كأس
كي يستخدم الكرملين كل سلاح في
حوزته بما في ذلك السلاح النووي.
الشمالية اطلقت مقذوفات يشتبه في
انها صواريخ باليستية ان مقذوفين
عمران خان. بوتين وعد واوفى. وها
هو بايدن يقطع وعودا على نفسه
فوق مكان بعيد مثل البحر الاسود
او ربما في الواقع ضد قاعدة
يا الهي لقد جن جنون المصارع
الشيشاني فهو متحمس للحرب
القادمة صاخبة جدا. وبينما ينتظر
الجميع كأس العالم في قطر.
سبوتنيك الروسية فماذا يقصد
بوتين بهذه العبارة اخشى ان يطفئ
ستحقق بفضل طائرات الجيل السادس
تفوقا ساحقا على الرئيسيين مثل
مع اربع عشرة دولة من دول جزر
المحيط الهادئ بما في ذلك جزر
المعيشة. وللمطالبة برفع الاجور
ليس فقط في بريطانيا بل حتى في
الالاف في شوارع اكبر المدن
البريطانية احتجاجا على غلاء
الصين تحتفل ولكن لا يكتمل
احتفالها الا بتهنئة ابن
النووية اكثر من مشاهدي قناة
شاهد للتعريف. ومن التهديد
والوعيد الى تحليل الوضع بكل
هدوء. هنا تقرير امريكي يحدد اين
العسكريين بحسب نيويورك تايمز ان
هناك امكانية لتفجير سلاح تكتيكي
لامبراخت. ومن التهديدات الفارغة
الى ردود الافعال الحاسمة. وخلال
تقصد المسيرات الايرانية ومن قوة
الهجوم الى الانسحاب فجأة القوات
من الغارات الجوية في المدينة
الوزيران تهديداتهما لروسيا لكن
اوكرانيا مهم للغاية للتصدي
للطائرات المسيرة بشكل خاص. فهل
فيها قوته حول قطعة الجاتوه التي
اقتصها قبل يومين. ليخرج هنا
الا ان تأخذ وقتها لبضع دقائق
كرست لادانة قرار الضم الروسي
الجنرالات الروس بسبب ذلك
الانسحاب قائلا ان الوقت قد حان
نظام من بين اربعة انظمة دفاع
جوي متطورة لاوكرانيا في الايام
المقبلة. وذلك حسب ما صرحت به
وزيرة الدفاع الالمانية كريستين
خطير يا سادة لتندلع هنا حرب
تمرير القرارات. نعم الولايات
المجنون لن يكون غريبا ابدا.
الغريب هو ان هذه هي رابع تجربة
حرب نتحدث يا سادة. المانيا تقدم
دعما عسكريا غير مسبوق لاوكرانيا
من مخبأ تحت الارض. هناك قالت
لمبرقت ان النظام الذي ستدعم به
الامن. قررت ان تثأر من روسيا
بنفسها نعم لقد قامت بتسليم اول
احشائه ها هو يلتهم عشرين من
اراضي اوكرانيا. ومن لديه اعتراض
بهذا الاجراء وبهذه الطريقة قررت
امريكا معاقبة الجزائر والسبب
المدلل ينتقد قوات روس في
اوكرانيا. فلماذا يا قديروف
الدولي يدين خطوة روسيا في ضم
اربعة اقاليم اوكرانية. ولكن مع
عن الجنون. فماذا فعل هذا الملاك
البريء تركيا تتهم واشنطن وتتوعد
تصريحات بوتين لن ترهب الولايات
المتحدة وحلفائها وحلف الناتو لن
يقف مكتوف الايدي. اما بوتين فلن
ينجو بفعلته. يا له من تهديد
حسابات امريكا وحلفائها. وبكين
ترعب واشنطن بسلاحها الجديد
والتحرك الامريكي ياتي فورا.
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي لا يتوقف
بوتين والحوثيون في اليمن يطلقون
تحذيرهم الاخير. روسيا تقول
لن ترهب الولايات المتحدة ولن
تنجو بفعلتك. اسمعت يا بوتين?
وعلى بلاده لكن من سيفي بتلك
الوعود الامريكية يا ترى?
وواشنطن تحدد وتتوقع الاهداف
التي سيضربها بوتين بسلاحه
هكذا قالها بايدن ليأتي الرد
الروسي سريعا بهذه الخطوة عن اي